[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you
already know the cash up is the number
one happened finance but did you realize
you can get the most powerful debit card
in the world with the cash shops cash
card just select a boost in your cash
app swipe the cash card and save 10% or
more at Whole Foods Shake Shack chipotle
taco bell chick-fil-a and all coffee
shops around the country all right
hmm download the cash app for free on
the App Store or Google Play market
[Music]
what's up babies hi how's everybody
doing um it's um right now for me Monday
the 20-something on january and i know
that i know that it's the date first of
all you can download my app and watch
the first 10 minutes of the podcast that
way before anybody else type it in
Crystal eeeh and all that [ __ ]
also I got Boni startled by they're all
sold out but I got a show in Milwaukee
Madison and also Chicago and hello
Chicago I added another show because it
sold out so quickly and that show sold
out in practically a day so I added a
third show in Chicago and that's on sale
now and it's selling out so Chicago's my
market I don't know what the deal is but
you know I
Chicago hey I don't know you know and I
normally don't say stuff like this but
Chicago loves your boy and so I don't
understand it but we're gonna go with it
because Chicago isn't that that song
Chicago my kind of town is another song
Chicago's my kinda town same no four
times tone-deaf but yeah I I love to go
and I'm gonna go this weekend and it's
going to be absolutely freezin but it's
also gonna be so [ __ ] hot when I go
back in July but I'm you know we'll see
if we add a fourth one but that's a lot
of tickets man that's going to be over
10,000 tickets and
market and I you know I don't normally
do this like I'm gonna do a lot of stuff
I don't normally do on the on the
podcast but uh hell but that's for you
show that's three free show so it won't
free show so yeah sporting the [ __ ]
babies look do them by the way the merch
is going crazy get it Gary picked extra
merch pick that scoop that up and then
bring it to the show and wear it I see
all you out there with your [ __ ]
wouldn't make a wouldn't make a dent
shirts and then I see also the baby
shirts and I see this shirt silhouette
on and I say the follow the leader tour
shirts it means you guys are helping me
back up the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
Brinks truck right now right so you guys
we're you know as you know we're trying
to keep the [ __ ] Brinks truck going
in Reverse and you know I mean I barely
goes forward anymore so okay that's
enough of that
yeah so the reso the reason why I know
what date it is is because DirecTV is
supposed to come to my [ __ ] house on
the 31st now I put out a little bit of a
hot freestyle on my Instagram my Twitter
and my YouTube about how I was feeling
about DIRECTV and my trouble is with
DirecTV now is DirecTV the worst
customer service on the planet yes it is
it's the worst customer service on the
planet you would get better customer
service from a hooker crack [ __ ] you
know you'd be like where is she
she was supposed to be here and give me
some crack and a [ __ ] but she's not
reliable and you'd be like well at least
we're not dealing with DIRECTV
apparently ever since DirecTV merged
with AT&T AT&T said [ __ ] it and just
want to get a bunch of new customers and
not keep the pre-existing customers
happy I don't know what the deal is what
I do know is I've called DirecTV like
they're my [ __ ] ex-girlfriend like
they're my ex-girlfriend and we're just
trying to [ __ ] salvage what we have
left but we can't I'm calling them too
much and they're not calling back which
is another thing why they're like my
ex-girlfriend okay that sucks and it's
absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous because
they're supposed to come let me
just break down the [ __ ] story for
you guys okay babies look here's what is
going on I'm not clearing my throat too
much yeah is it because it's that time
of year yeah is it coming from my throat
and my [ __ ] the post-nasal yeah did I
put cream in my coffee which I never do
and it activated a little bit more this
morning yes are we gonna get through it
yeah but um yeah so I want two extra
boxes of [ __ ] DirecTV now here's what
we're not gonna do okay
mother [ __ ] nobody's gonna say whoa
first world problems we're not gonna do
that do you know why because you're
listening to this podcast therefore in
the first world okay nobody's listening
to the podcast in a [ __ ] Hut so don't
be such a [ __ ] you know I when people
say that kind of [ __ ] it drives me nuts
well first world problems because you're
only saying that on the Internet which
means in the first world you're
commenting it under a YouTube vid get in
the first world okay so I all my
problems are first word problem you know
why I'm in the first world baby so
anyway I called DirecTV now already I
don't wanna so
DirecTV you better make it easy now do
they make it easy no why don't they make
it easy because they already have me as
a customer they don't think I'll cancel
what they don't know is your boy will
cancel and your boy will go to dish your
boy will take the dish off the top of
the [ __ ] house and he will bring it
down in the front yard leave it there
and have a guy drive by and pick it up I
don't give a [ __ ] is it gonna cost me
money doesn't matter we're out here to
prove a point
plus my Brinks trucks ah so I mean we
all know which direction they go so I
call the [ __ ] DirecTV guy now let's
do a guess does he speak English well
you already know all right
so hello how you doing I will talk to
hello this is a directive al-arab now
let him know Lala okay yeah cool well
first of all I want to see really value
you as a customer stop right there
you don't need to tell me how much you
value me as a customer because you
actually aren't DirecTV you're just a
guy they hired you don't give a [ __ ] you
have your own family you go home and you
forget about my phone call and that's
fine dude that is absolutely fine so
don't say the [ __ ] transcript [ __ ]
don't say the [ __ ] that they tell you to
say I'm a person you purse let's do this
okay and he says oh so what's the
problem what's going on I said I just
want two boxes and he says okay now oh
let me give you a [ __ ] backstory the
guy when they first showed up and gave
me the first boxes they came up the
first guy that came big Samoan type
looking dude comes in hey what's up I
said oh hey I'm we need to put boxes
over here and he says I can't do that if
the guy's not here if you're video audio
guys in here I said really and he said
yeah I said okay so can you come when
can you come next time he said Fri
Friday I said that's perfect that's what
my video audio guys coming oh and he
said okay I said can you make the
appointment and he said sure I said can
you make it right now in front of me and
he said sure he pulled up his little
[ __ ] thing that look like a Palm
Pilot hey DirecTV is and Palm Pilots and
he [ __ ] plugged it in he said cool
appointments all set for Friday I said
oh great he said it to my face I looked
at his eyes and this Samoan guy said it
to my face so he left
Friday ah what the [ __ ] you guessed it
the video audio guy was the only guy
that showed up the [ __ ] DirecTV guy
didn't show up so when the video audio
guy showed up I asked him and I said hey
man they said that they couldn't do it
without you and he said oh that's
[ __ ] they do it all the time and I
said huh so not only did he lie and was
he a lazy [ __ ] oh he's not here when he
said he would be so they came the next
day and did it a new a new guy a
different guy came did it without the
video on an audio guy and still did it
so that first guy is lying alright so
everybody's a goddamn liar at DIRECTV so
far I've dealt with except for the new
guy
so now I'm already pissed when I'm
calling so I called him up and I say hey
I need two boxes and he says okay I say
send me the confirmation and he says ok
we can send a confirmation I said a
Kenya he said what's the email could I
send it to I said why don't you just
text it to me so I get it right now and
he says okay can do it right now but
we'll get it to you in the an hour I
said so to be clear you're texting me
I said what's my phone number he told me
my phone number I said so be clear
you're texting me is this confirmation
in one hour and he said yes I said great
so we'll have it in one hour and if I
don't I'll come back and he says okay
now the video now the call was was
already by the way they record all these
call for for [ __ ] whatever purpose
they record these bullshit's for you
need to [ __ ] listen to these back
again okay anyway I wait I sit and I
[ __ ] wait I literally sit and I wait
for one hour the second the hour goes by
I check my [ __ ] texts absolutely
nothing just text from fuck-ups friends
family members so I call them
immediately and I get guess what a new
person which is highly [ __ ] annoying
but I get it okay so now it's a female
all good a little bit better to deal
with can I understand a word she's
saying
no so she's saying I I explained to her
what I just explained to you what
happened and she says okay well we'll
send you we'll make sure that the thing
I said oh wait the first guy I [ __ ]
talk he I said hey I need a guy to come
out Thursday and he says okay well let
me check okay well earliest I could come
in Saturday I said oh no we can't do
that he's got to come Thursday's as well
unfortunately we kind of have it we
can't have it a Saturday oh we can't
have a Thursday we have to have a
Saturday I said I will see what you got
to do is you got to move some stuff
around I don't really care what you do
but guys got to come Thursday how's that
sound and the guy says well let me check
okay so we can have them come Thursday
so now now I'm pissed
cuz he could have done it what changed
in the last second just me saying no do
it
alright so now he said all that I did
get the confirmation so okay now I'm
call no flashback no flashback far go
back forward to the [ __ ] lady
so now I'm talking I said yeah can you
do the thing I didn't get the [ __ ]
confirmation text and she says okay I
don't know why you didn't get it but we
can we can guarantee you get a
confirmation text within 24 hours and I
said well now the first guy said I could
get it in an hour but you're telling me
I can't get it in an hour I have to get
it in 24 hours and she says yes I said
well why that first guy tell me one hour
Jesus I don't know because you're not
the [ __ ] guy that's why because
you're not the [ __ ] guy you're a
different person in this how you do it
you keep pawning people off until you're
[ __ ] the guy gives up but I'm not
giving up man oh I don't give up do it
I'm not giving up so I say okay so
you're telling me to be clear in 24
hours I'm gonna have an email and it's
gonna tell me that you're coming
Thursday Jesus yes absolutely I said
what's your name she says her name I
don't remember it now I meant to
remember it it's okay I wait now I do I
go about my day I say I eat I sleep I
[ __ ] wake up in the morning and I'm
waiting I'm waiting 1 p.m.
I'm waiting cuz that's 24-hour mark
guess what the 24-hour mark goes by no
[ __ ] texts no texts I check my email
I get an email guess what the email says
the email says a guy will be at your
place from noon to 4:00 any time in
between there and get this it says he's
coming today the day I get the email now
we are 5 days away from Thursday there
confirmed god damn place that they were
coming today this is when I get the
email 12:10
he's coming from 12 to 4 today I get the
email at 12:10 so already 10 minutes and
I'm not home I never said nobody said
[ __ ] about today nobody said [ __ ]
[ __ ] about anybody coming today nobody
[ __ ] about it me her guy nobody said
[ __ ] guess what your boy does that on
his phone I never typed the thing faster
I go into recent calls
that's that clear I [ __ ] hit it um
and then I [ __ ] get a new guy and I
and I explained to him everything I just
explained to you babies okay and I say I
want a [ __ ] email confirming your
coming Thursday and I want it now and he
says well unfortunately I can't send you
an email that's not my jurisdiction I
said okay when can I get the email now
this is Saturday
he says ASAP is all I can say I say okay
ASAP
so uh now I sit and I wait Sunday rolls
around no email Sunday night I'm getting
so pissed no email so I start firing off
a few tweets I start firing off a tweet
certain and I'm going to dish
threatening I'm only gonna use Netflix
start in front of me using Hulu
threatening am using PlayStation
threatening I'm gonna get him a [ __ ]
streaming service from Carrick I don't
give a [ __ ] okay
they my phone rings it's an 800 number
my [ __ ] my [ __ ] phone ring my phone
rings don't know the [ __ ] thing pick
it up oh hello that's all I hear I say
yeah who's this Delia Delia lalalalala I
say no I hear DIRECTV I said are you
from DIRECTV and he says yes I say are
you column is lalalala Twitter
he's yo have you ever had DirecTV call
you out of the [ __ ] blue it was
amazing
so I say listen man I he called me
because I started tweeting and in there
they're in my DMS what's your account
number we need to pull it up we need to
know your account number to this and
that you don't need to know [ __ ]
dude you know who the [ __ ] I am I'm
tweeting I got my account number I got
it all it's all there
I'm not telling another [ __ ] bot I
got a call a [ __ ] bot I got a call a
bot now I dealt with three people they
didn't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
now I gotta tell the Twitter I'm bot my
[ __ ] you got the clothes recorded man
you record them for [ __ ] purposes ah
go in there see what the [ __ ] problem
is are you coming
Thursday no confirmation email I say
check my [ __ ] account I'm at dinner
with my [ __ ] family
check my [ __ ] account you comin the
guy says I can see there is an
appointment where you believe are coming
Thursday I say great still no no email
still no email but they're coming they
told me dude now let me tell you when I
get this is unbelievable that they said
that they [ __ ] work when I get off
this podcast you better [ __ ] believe
I'm calling the DirecTV and I'm calling
them and I'm asking them for a [ __ ]
dude I'm calling them every goddamn day
until Thursday and if you if you think
I'm if you think I'm telling you
[ __ ] then you are [ __ ] absolutely
out to lunch dude I can't wait to I want
to be annoyed I want to be annoyed if
you're gonna play this game I'm gonna be
annoyed and you're dealing with this
[ __ ] and I'm so happy with
situations like this that I have 800
thousand Twitter followers and [ __ ]
1.4 million Instagram followers that's
why I had to put the hottest freestyle
out on my [ __ ] Instagram talking
about DIRECTV and YouTube it's
you tube dude I'm shutting DirecTV down
if you're not by the way if you don't
show up Thursday
oh it's it that's it that's it dude I'm
putting out a [ __ ] album dude I'm
doing I'm putting together a [ __ ]
well-crafted comedy bit and doing it on
stage and opening my next special with
it that's what I'm doing if you don't
show up Thursday and I'm switching the
dish I'm a matter of fact if you don't
come I'm taking all the dish employees
out to dinner dude that's what I'm doing
and I'm wining and dining them and I'm
gonna make [ __ ] love to them do it
and they're gonna want to and I'm gonna
show them a [ __ ] beautiful time and
we're gonna have a great relationship
I'll be in all the dish employees I
don't give a [ __ ] if they're guys or
girls it's not a gay or straight thing
it's a [ __ ] retaliation thing to you
[ __ ] on Direct TV because I
don't [ __ ] around with this [ __ ] dude
if I make an appointment with somebody
and we say 10:30 on [ __ ] first of all
I don't make an appointment that says oh
yeah it's gonna be between noon and 4:00
I'll show up sometime no if that
happened I wouldn't be successful you
[ __ ] dunces I I'm sorry to talk about
this so much but [ __ ] you know
also if you have DirecTV you know what's
up dude I need to put a [ __ ] hit out
on your [ __ ] at DIRECTV
this is unbelievable the employees you
have the customer service you have is
[ __ ] terrible anyway dude
uh you know it's it's just you know
firstworldproblems is what it is but
it's all good
I bought by the way I never talked did I
talk about this last time on the [ __ ]
podcast about how the difference between
Colorado and Utah did I do Denver is the
[ __ ] Denver I'm I'm excluding Denver
from this conversation Denver hey nice
to meet you Denver let's have a
wonderful relationship that's what I did
with them [ __ ] eight years ago and
every time I go back to Denver it's a
great time I walk around and it's
[ __ ] beautiful I look around and of
course Denver is a little bit
hoity-toity they like to act like they
[ __ ] the Rockies didn't weren't just
invented the the Colorado Rockies the
baseball team wasn't an expansion team
in the 90s seriously go [ __ ] yourself
with that [ __ ] you gotta act like oh
yeah you're so [ __ ] you're so welcome
that you're in Denver hey you know isn't
it amazing
like I can't pack up and go somewhere
else and just perform there and make the
[ __ ] bags oh yeah thank you so much
for letting me come perform to you like
like I'm the lucky one
bags I'll get bags anywhere dude I'll
get bags in [ __ ] Florida
I'll get bags in Calgary but it's cold
dude I'm going to [ __ ] MKE get in bags
on [ __ ] Friday dude I'll build a
snowman dude I'll catch a cold I don't
give a [ __ ] where I am Oh
congratulations
hey congratulations you're in [ __ ]
Denver in April oh okay bags bottom line
bags bottom line I'm [ __ ] out the door
of the Learjet arm extended in a
scooping motion
bags you understand I'll go to [ __ ]
Chicago and get bags you say it shitty
alright I'll go to [ __ ] Chicago or
Fargo and get bags
all right so I don't give a [ __ ] now I
started by saying Denver's awesome and I
kind of heard off into everything
another [ __ ] okay let's not forget the
Rockies are an expansion team in
nineteen whatever then and then and then
you know what I mean
when anytime someone asks oh [ __ ] yeah
weeds legal nanana and then they're okay
first of all we doesn't need to be legal
you can get high anywhere nobody gives a
[ __ ]
yeah but weeds legal all right cool you
can get I can get weed from my [ __ ]
neighbor and they're a family okay I can
literally ring the doorbell be like do
you guys have weed and they'll be like
no I think we got some lying around and
they're a family okay uh so went to
Boulder and I want to talk about you
know cuz I talked about a little bit but
I want to talk about it more on this
podcast I went to Boulder and I went to
Colorado Springs lighten the [ __ ] up
Boulder okay because here's the thing
that I started thinking about more
Boulder every time I look people were
like where you going next I'd be like
I'm going to Utah under the go is it
weird over there no it's not it's not
weird over there it's not weird over
there Boulder you're weird okay now
that's not everybody in Boulder but do
the crowds there you guys need to [ __ ]
and relax
all right you guys need to relax because
guess what that makes comedians want to
do come more full throttle and you can't
even deal with [ __ ] half throttle you
can't deal with Mach 6 and that makes us
want to go Mach [ __ ] 10 dude dude
Boulder Colorado Springs Colorado
Springs and Boulder some mark ass
[ __ ] and their and when you go there
and then they're like Oh
Colorado is it weird to these these
liberal cities these hippie [ __ ]
liberal cities okay these hip hippie
flannel-wearing cargo pant [ __ ]
liberal cities which by the way are a
goddamn beautiful looking okay but I
went to [ __ ] Salt Lake City and they
were the [ __ ] now let's stop pretending
people pretend like these [ __ ]
button-up buttoned up blazer we're in
[ __ ] audiences are tough when it's
not the truth dude it is not the truth
do you know who the tough audiences are
those [ __ ] quote unquote easygoing
liberal [ __ ] chilling ass
[ __ ] weeds weed smoke and ass
because you know why dude because you
get offended so much it used to be the
opposite in the 90s it used to be the
opposite Republicans and Democrats
Democrats Republicans now it's not about
being Republican or Democrat Democrats
it's just about just relax do it I did a
[ __ ] joke about something that
literally never happened in the history
of the world and they got offended you
can't get offended at a joke that's net
that a joke that doesn't mean that has
no basis in truth that that that has
never happened in the history of the
world you're gonna get upset about that
and then I went to Salt Lake City which
Boulder was like aw it's gonna be weird
and I went to Salt Lake City and heads
floated emoji head explosion emoji come
on dude you you think you're not the way
you are that's my nightmare that's my
nightmare you think you're not the way
you are that's my nightmare if anybody
was like to me that's that's my 100
percent number one nightmare world like
you think you're a man of the people and
people are like dude one thing about
that guy is he is not the man of the
people
I think I'm [ __ ] secure and not
insecure and a [ __ ] confident guy and
everyone behind my back is like dude
that guy's so insecure if you think
you're one way and you're the actual
other way people like that exist dude a
lot of most people are like that no no
no no no no dude that is my [ __ ]
nightmare I want to be the way I think I
am otherwise it's it's over dude
otherwise it's [ __ ] real over it's
real over otherwise you think you're the
way you are you think you're the [ __ ]
dude you think you're a certain way and
you're the other way imagine being a
[ __ ] fat guy and thinking you're
pumping iron you walk in a room and was
like oh there's a fat guy
that's what you're doing dude come on
man just relax
don't get offended at something that
never happened quip the new year means
new resolutions and we've got one you're
working on twice everyday it's your oral
health and with a quip electric
toothbrush sticking to good habits is
simple the guiding features are like a
built-in support system for better
brushing sensitive sonic vibrations for
an effective clean that's gentle on your
sensitive gun gums why people brush too
hard and some electric toothbrushes are
too abrasive but these aren't I use them
built-in two-minute timer pulses every
30 seconds to remind you when it
switched sides and help you clean your
home out evenly up to 90% of us don't
brush for a full two minutes or don't
clean evenly so this helps you the
multi-use cover works as it at us as a
stand it's cool that looks nice it's not
just like around like all the other
toothbrushes mounts to mirrors and
slides over your bristles to pack and
protect your clip on the go plus there
are no wires or clunky charger it runs
for three months without a problem and
it's all good brush heads are
automatically delivered every three
months for just five dollars a friendly
reminder when it's time to for a refresh
and just a committed to your oral oral
health your healthy every other way come
on man you got to be healthy with this
in your mouth I love quip at home and on
the road it makes my mouth feel good and
that's why I love quip and over 1
million happy healthy mouths do to quip
starts at just $25 and if you go to get
quip calm Congrats
get quip calm slash Congrats right now
you can get your first refill pack free
that's your first refill pack free at GE
tqu IP comm / Congrats cash app you
already know the cash app is the number
one happened finance but did you realize
you can get the most powerful debit card
in the world with the cash apps cash
card the cash card comes with boosts a
feature you can't get anywhere else
because cash app invented it do you want
to roll with inventors yeah I do so get
the cash out just select a Boosh a boost
in your cash app swipe the cash card and
save 10% or more
Whole Foods Shake Shack Chipotle Taco
Bell chick-fil-a and all coffee shops
around the country it works a lot of
different places and it's great the
coffee shop boost takes $1 off at any
coffee shop including Dunkin and
Starbucks see here's the deal if you're
a mathematician like I am you can
understand this you drink 100 cups a
year that's save $100 it's that simple
become a part of the greatest rewards
program ever and download the cash app
now it's the number one app for a reason
and the cash card is the only debit card
with boosts and of course when you
download the cash app and enter the
referral code Congrats
you'll receive $5 and the cash app will
send $5 to the times up Legal Defense
Fund visit the App Store or Google Play
market and download the cash app um
anyway yeah that's it I'm sweating but I
sweat for you [ __ ] do you
understand look what I'm wearing my joy
my Jordan Elevens because they match
with the baby's top I forgot to have a
fan why don't I hit it BAM if you're
with somebody a good joke you do is when
you open up the window in a car or if a
fan is turn on the painting just go
anyway just trying to help your [ __ ]
well if you're having sex with a girl
girls I have a question for you if
you're having sex with a guy and when
right was he's about to climax and he
said oh I'm about to crust a nut what
would you what would you do
think about it pause the podcast now and
what would you do
uh-oh about to crust a nut would you
ever see that guy again man oh I'm bout
to crust a nut [ __ ] dude that's so
gangster oh man
remember that oh I'm Diane I'm so cool
episode that was maybe my favorite part
of the whole podcast damn I remember I
was recording that in New York in a
hotel in my [ __ ] hotel on my bet on
my couch just like honk hunched over
recording talking of what a mad dude if
you have a puck as you're a madman
basically especially if it's just you if
you have a guest fine
what's up with [ __ ] dude we talk [ __ ]
all these hippies like Nick Swardson
Theo me Bryan Callen Schaub you know
whatever we'll [ __ ] talk [ __ ] on
Twitter to each other and people just
don't understand that we're [ __ ] with
each other people will just be like whoa
is this real like especially with Theo
Theo talks a lot of [ __ ] on his podcast
and he'll just be like uh and then
people be like dude is this be for real
like what are you talk what are you yeah
it's real good yeah just whatever you
want man you know people [ __ ] are so
dumb dude people are so dumb I did the
[ __ ] DirecTV freestyle by the way
play a little bit of it so you guys know
what the [ __ ] is up in by the way no I'm
not pissed this is bad dude that's
enough of that look
okay these are people who subscribe to
my YouTube that are my fans
quote-unquote okay let me find these of
course they were when somebody puts the
diss light hits dislike and then it's
always seven dislikes or from DirecTV
employees yeah okay man that jokes good
keep doing that somebody writes
of course I saw it last night this idiot
took me until the end to realize he
wasn't the driver I'm driving [ __ ] so
I can't now of course I can't find him
at all
but here's one somebody wrote the other
night
what was it dude
he didn't try him once this is horrible
didn't even rhyme but still was pretty
funny
yeah really dude really Tiger dragon
unbelievable dude oh this guy sounds
like old school Beastie Boys hey man no
it doesn't this this is the [ __ ] that
kills me this right here there's not
much rhyming but good rhythm on the beat
like what dude what are you talking
about it's horrible and it's I'm a
comedian well how do I'm a comedian I am
NOT a rapper and I'm making fun and I'm
doing this how on earth does somebody
have a brain that first of all thinks
was not really rhyming but it's good
rhythm and then that then makes it and
then types it
but I have real beef though with these
shits here's how I novel people by the
way dude rhyming sucks
I would never rhyme I would never ever
rhyme if I rhyme it's by mistake that's
my [ __ ] do it if I'm a rapper that's it
I'm not rhyming I want to be a real
rapper to die kid I should [ __ ]
really really try to be a real rapper
and nah I don't rhyme dude
cuz that's dude you're a 30 year old
rapper and you're hardcore but you're
just rhyming no we've talked about this
before but no dude by the way nobody
likes DIRECTV still it should
technically be her fault
it's pretty good though um anyway I'm
[ __ ] do you guys argue is ready for the
saga the DirecTV saga
I guess ready to hear next week to see
this is a two-parter pretty much
directively two-parter
I had a two-parter dude I don't know
what but I don't know what to [ __ ]
hang on the road and I got a [ __ ] I
by the way I've rescheduled my [ __ ]
Shh yeah why are people saying I
canceled my st. Louis show I didn't
cancel it i rescheduled it so more
people could come uh
wow dude I [ __ ] went on I fired on
all cylinders on that DirecTV story and
I'm so chilling right now I'm so chillin
man basically me doing that DirecTV
story was like me and a [ __ ] cupcake
and now I'm just crashing baby do it I
love you I love you guys listening man I
love you guys listening to my [ __ ] to
my [ __ ] man I'm just iced ice this
podcast we stay went in for 28 minutes
and then and then the rest we just do
talk about [ __ ] on Craigslist and we
talk about [ __ ] on to on Twitter and
we're [ __ ] did you see the guy who
[ __ ] had a road rage and jumped on
the guy's car and then the guy and then
and then drove on the freeway and went
up to 70 miles an hour and the guy was
on the guy's hood like he was a [ __ ]
Vin Diesel character and he was like 70
dude and then they pulled over and the
guy wouldn't get off the guy's hood and
the cops were like drawing their guns
and [ __ ]
dude it was unbelievable imagine being
that mad I imagine being that mad see
that's so funny too cuz you get that mad
and then you jump on a guy's hood and
then in well how many seconds do you
think okay wait I'm not mad anymore I'm
scared for my life and how many seconds
six at the most and then you're not even
mad you're just thinking okay you know
what
I have to stay pretending this mad
because I don't want to look like a
[ __ ] idiot because if I if I if I now
act like I'm not mad and I just made a
mistake then I'm a chump right the guy's
got it he's only holding on now because
of ego that how weird is the [ __ ]
human brain like that would you Google
road-rage let's just look at the [ __ ]
right here so it says got these stupid
[ __ ] things I mean he's on the thing
after getting into a 65 year old man
clung to the hood of a car as it sped
down a Massachusetts highway for three
miles I was too long unbelievable look
at this he's yelling dude you stopped
the car you stopped the car another man
confronted the driver with a gun after
seeing the man hey man making it worse
imagine seeing a guy on a hood of a car
going 70 miles an hour and thinking oh
gotta get my gun you know dude I know
what'll make this better
my gun that's so that's like thinking I
know it'll make this better
my pet bear it's just a bad idea dude
and get off this [ __ ] thing man look
at they bleeped it out
another man confronted the driver with a
gun after seeing the man cleaning
through the hood for dear life
dear life it's always dear life if this
guy's life isn't that dear he's on the
[ __ ] hood of a car there we go so he
he gets out he's got a gun the man on
top of the car Richard Kim rouse Key
says he got on the hood after a minor
accident with the driver yeah man why
the driver of the car 37 year old mark
Fitzgerald tried to leave the scene
after the accident and cam raske ended
up on the hood ended up you know
kamarowsky said he is thankful for the
Good Samaritans who helped stop
Fitzgerald all [ __ ] off dude [ __ ] off
[Music]
unbelievable the man with the gun and
another witness kept Fitzgerald until
the troops arrived other troopers
arrived
[Music]
dude
why did any of this happen why did any
of this happen this looks so [ __ ]
stupid if you go on YouTube these grown
men look so [ __ ] stupid imagine
jumping on someone's a car because
you're mad at them and not getting off
and then imagine the guy you're in the
car imagine the other guy you're in the
car and you drive off imagine being that
[ __ ] pea-brained dude you got
families in [ __ ] right the guys dressed
up in a [ __ ] sweater these [ __ ]
idiots they [ __ ] got to learn
lessons dude people have to learn
lessons I sound like [ __ ] Travis
Bickle we gotta wash away two scum the
rats the kansai man when he was just
said the constant you're like whoa
does he even or am I just [ __ ] sexist
I don't know who cares anyway uh yeah
let's do Twitter questions or some [ __ ]
are we gonna do the the misconnections
the what we got both huh we could look
at you guys I gotta do twitch I could
make million all in all you need are
[ __ ] big titties and if you do twitch
or minor you just unzip your top a
little bit and play video games I mean
you know mm-hmm the [ __ ] I wouldn't
get rid of his going like yeah but dude
the fact that he's going like a and not
know that's not true is a [ __ ]
travesty so it's all good kind of proof
I'm a little bit right the fact that you
could be like wow it already is like get
the [ __ ] outta here
how does every girl on Instagram not
have at least at least 50,000 followers
is what I want to know started out my
babies dude these [ __ ] instagrams man
they get worse and worse I saw a girl
that was showing how to workout and I
swear to God she was wearing tight pants
and she kept bending over and doing
deadlifts and the camera was of her back
and you could see her fried butterfly
her [ __ ] was basically out ah hey call
your parents to it you could see the
different lips you know what I mean like
the different [ __ ] the [ __ ] stacks
of lips through her pants hey stop
filming immediately call your parents
how about parents call your daughter hey
what is she doing hey dude God hopefully
they won't I love when they're like
hopefully Instagram won't delete this
hopefully haters won't [ __ ] report
this hey man huh you're showing your
[ __ ] yeah I get it look I think anyone
should be able to show their [ __ ] it
whenever but that's not the world we
live in so don't show your [ __ ] on inst
you showing your puss on inst you need
to call your parents
you got millions and millions of
followers because you're showing
everything but your areola but for real
you know it just shows how dumb guys are
oh what a sexy baby they'll be like oh I
you know it's unbelievable dude these
comments but it's weird how many guys
from the [ __ ] Middle East will just
go nah they'll do they go [ __ ] ham on
Instagram like I would like a [ __ ]
suck you one time I was uh at the coffee
bean years ago the block I used to run
just [ __ ] killing it I used to eat a
salad then go to coffee bean chill out
there's a gas station there hang out
just [ __ ] killing it I was about 26 I
would kill it on that [ __ ] coffee
bean blocked that block was hot but um
and this security guard came up to me
security guard like I don't know how
legit he was we did a security uniform
on and like at at least a Taser I don't
know if it would he had a gun but and he
walked up to me my friends and he was
like hey man look at this and I said
yeah
he showed me a DVD this was back when
DVDs were still a thing of [ __ ] like
backyard [ __ ] it's already I'm like
okay and he's like look at these girls
on this cover and I said yeah he said
guy just gave me this I'm gonna go home
and watch this and [ __ ] jerk off I
will [ __ ] these girls so good and I was
like okay hey man can you surveil the
area please
hey man do me a favor put that in your
car and just kind of look for Nair do
elves look for Nair dwellers please can
you just do me a favor and just kind of
walk around that gas station for a
little bit and put that DVD of backyard
[ __ ] in your trunk you know and I was
just like yeah yeah yeah would [ __ ] them
I would [ __ ] them so good I make them
come so much he said that's what he said
yeah oh really
why don't you do me a favor and pop on
over to your car there and just throw
that in the backseat and then walk
around coffee bean and use looking you
know last thing you want is a security
guard coming up to you ever ever ever no
matter what the circumstance hey guess
what you never want a security guard
walking up to you do you know why that
means they're either was is or will be a
problem I never want security guards
coming up to me okay
amplify that how much I don't want a
security guard coming up to me with a
[ __ ] DVD of backyard [ __ ] telling me
how much he's going to make the girls on
the DVD come and then you have mental
problems all good go get checked out
first of all put the DVD either in the
trash or in your back seat finish your
shift don't touch your gun or taser and
then at the end go to a doctor what's
that guy doing now you ever think about
that what that what's that guy doing now
like the guys that you had in your past
like what are they doing now like like
one time a guy came up I was at the same
coffee bean and he was like I don't
remember what he was saying were you
with us when he was like doing the thing
he was like it still win
what was he saying he was just talking
about how oh he's talking about how
women [ __ ] up lives or something like
that like he was so distraught and
obviously going through a divorce or
something like that
and he knelt down and he was saying you
wonder why we're all [ __ ] up it's the
women and we were all just like okay but
man what's that guy doing now is he with
the security guard or they all [ __ ]
crusts and nuts over and watching the
[ __ ] backyard [ __ ] DVD maybe I was
list I was listening to this [ __ ]
thing but Jon Ronson dude his audible
[ __ ] is good I was listening to it on
about the but it's called the butterfly
effect Jon Ronson you ever like read a
book by a guy that's a real guy and then
you look him up and you realized that he
doesn't sound anything like what the
[ __ ] you thought maybe he'd sound like I
thought Jon Ronson sounded like me kinda
just and I could maybe that's my fault
like I'm just me being egotistical but I
was like this guy's a cool guy probs
like me and then I listened to his
audible book and he's fascinated with
the porn industry and sex and everything
so I love him
by the way he's great but I listened to
the butterfly effect and it was about
the inner the the boom of the free porn
on the internet and how pornhub kind of
took over and how this guy named Fabian
made like a billion billion dollars off
this [ __ ] free porn and the butterfly
effect of it you know and how it
affected everybody and porn and
everybody outside of porn and all the
[ __ ] but it's pretty wild but the way
Jon Ronson talks
it makes me it's like it's very hypnotic
and he's very he's British and he's very
the way he talks about the butterfly
effect about if I but if I flaps his
wings and in the third chapter we were
fine by the end of it a man has to move
to the outskirts of Oklahoma because he
is not wanted in his community and by
the end of the fifth chapter this is
what he says in the beginning there will
be a man who hires a bunch of porn
to set fire to his very expensive stamp
collection but so he starts talking
about all the all the [ __ ] porn
butterfly effect and it's crazy that
erectile dysfunction has been gone has
rocketed up 1,000% and if I told you the
ages were 18 to 25 how would that make
you feel yeah dude because of porn if I
told you that porn actors to get aroused
right before they have sex with a live
woman are sitting looking at porn on
their phone
apparently guys now porn guys instead of
like getting aroused by the woman
they're about to have sex with they're
watching porn on their phone they're
like that's the new fluffer boners are
going [ __ ] down bro
boners are going down boners are like a
fighter jet in World War 2 dude they're
going down that's what's up man the
butterfly effect
what's a butterfly effected this podcast
is what I want to know log get more log
cabins people using catch for annoying
catchphrases people wearing [ __ ]
shirts that say wouldn't make a dent
people definitely broke up because of
this podcast would you believe that
listening to the congradulations podcast
has convinced couples of breaking up but
you can
would you be convinced that people are
annoying their families by telling them
it wouldn't make a dent
would you beacon would you understand
how annoyed families are by other people
calling themselves babies when they're
well into their 30s or 40s and telling
people that they need to keep Brinks
trucks going in Reverse how annoyed
would you be if you were family member
and your uncle who considers himself a
baby even though he's 52 would tell you
constantly that your nose was facing his
nose well it should be when it should be
facing the same way and you should be
standing in front of him so he could be
inside of you a conch what would you say
to someone who told you
goo gunk understanding you close to you
and you need them to stand further away
because they need to hear the sound of
the door closed and that sound sounds
eerily similar to you saying
kachunk but you're a baby um yeah man
anyway we're on ransom is the [ __ ] okay
so let's do what are your columns yeah
miss connect
not my babies you love the ribbon
misconnections you love the
misconnections here we go well let's
start off with a fire one here we go
smell your socks females only okay okay
smell your socks females only Wow
I want your sweaty drip down socks hey
what drip down socks
I want your sweaty drip down socks from
after work then Jim or just have it or
just have them on for days who the [ __ ]
wears their socks for days des laundry
Baldwin Park if you're in for a [ __ ]
if you want some creep to smell your
socks but that's all that you've got to
want because you can't contact this guy
with unsolicited services or offers so
okay I'm interesting oh my god this
title right here at beef oh my the body
of this one
I have googled beef countless times and
never found anything as magnificent as
you it would imagine
first of all ever googling beef and then
doing it twice but then doing it so many
times you can't count sounds like you
got props sounds like you guys stop
googling it sounds like you guys stop
googling things you know there Wow
imagine seeing someone you think is so
[ __ ] fly and then being like hold on
dude I got a Google beef to see if I can
find something better than that this is
because of the butterfly effect on free
porn I swear to God imagine seeing
someone out at a market or a square
thinking that they look so fantastic and
ravishing that you immediately pull up
your iPhone and Google beef that imagine
googling
again and then imagine googling it so
many times that you cannot count it then
imagine posting on an ad on Craigslist
and writing in the subject at beef and
then in the body
I have googled beef countless times and
never found anything as magnificent as
you and then imagine hoping that the
person you originally saw that was
better than this so cold beef you were
googling countless times stumbled upon
this ad on Craigslist and knew exactly
what you were talking about and then
imagine them getting in contact with you
or what oh wow I love this title simply
unload well you know he's talking about
[ __ ] crust n' mail for mail 27 downy
lot of these guys are in downey what's
going on in downy 27 good looks drug and
disease-free i traveler host down to
swap oral or just give or receive maybe
more let me know what you have in mind
do not contact me with he's open though
what do you mean do not contact I travel
or host down a swap oral or just give or
receive maybe more what do you mean do
not contact me some unsolicited offers
sure dude that's my favorite swap oral
like they're baseball cards like you're
[ __ ] trying to trade a [ __ ] Darryl
Strawberry for for a ken griffey jr. hey
dude you down a swap oral here's my
[ __ ] Kevin Moss rookie card can I
trade it for all of your Hensley mule
ends you know there another one sewing
circle oh wow see I get it you got to be
in the crew you got to be kind of in all
ready you gotta be well into this
Craigslist [ __ ] I already know what this
is because I don't even what I mean
sewing circle that's that the body then
just no that's the [ __ ] title and
then in the body it just simply says
unzipping comparing releasing okay I
guess this guy wants to just unzip and
be like this is my [ __ ] what's yours
look like I'll cool
all right cool let's [ __ ] let's crust
let's crust let's see what's up here we
go about the crystal nut all right cool
all right man hey well we'll catch you
later I'll see you on Craigslist hey man
how's it going
we got to start this off course all
right okay okay all right well cool I'll
catch you later man whose is bigger I
think yours is bigger all right well
I'll catch you later man
okay yep yep catch you later
thanks for the crusting oh wow the
titles of these just get better and
better I swear to God this one is titled
face time come ah looking for another
guy packing big that wants to come
together on FaceTime DL one-time thing
send pic I like how this guy's already
like I'm not starting a relationship
with you dude this is for [ __ ]
FaceTime coming and that's it I'm
gangster dude dude I would do that but
if I was gay I would do that but [ __ ]
straight up I would have liked the only
way I would be able to [ __ ] get it
going would be if like how dope put it
you know what I'm not gay but I'm
tempted to [ __ ] do it just to have
this [ __ ] going on in the background
while the guys going while you're doing
it hey how's it going you ready all
right here we go
and then this is in the background dude
we got it I have [ __ ] read YouTube
read why is this not signed in dude we
got to sign it in I mean this ad dude
[ __ ] these ads skip out to have this
going on the background for some reason
this what I thought it'd feel like this
hey man what's up you know this is a
one-time thing right all right cool
oh my god I wonder if you would mention
it if this was just blaring in the
background
[Music]
and then you go oh okay cool thanks man
room one type thing Jim
hey dude what's up man hey bro take it
out and you'll be doing like this guy
think I would think it was so weird but
I would crust thanks man you know
let's get these other guys going let's
see what's up up we got another customer
[Music]
hey guy what up how's it going dude hey
well you're big like me wow you know
this has to be on the DL right okay cool
very close one time thing you know that
right okay cool so anyway check it out
look here we go man you did the group
FaceTime what's up guys how's it go oh
man we got up we got a bunch oh I got
group Haysom although I'll have the
updated [ __ ] software boom hey guys
how's it going do it pull it out you
know there's a one time thing right
oh [ __ ] here we go and there's so many
of you thanks guys video I want to do it
just for that Fine Young Cannibals
playing in the background do two fine
young cannibals you know Fine Young
Cannibals killer dude that's amazing
oh wait I have a better song dude I have
a way better song - do it - Wow dude Wow
the best suggest I never look at
suggested videos after this Thank You
YouTube hey what's up I got right here
got another customer boom hey what's up
you ready take it out take it out all
right cuz hasn't means herself [ __ ] up
the funny part to joke of it
[Laughter]
all right there we go take it out well
you're big like me man catch you later
bloom this song this is one of the
greatest songs of all time for real I
used to listen to this in my car with my
dad oh man and my dad and I would play
it
my dad would play it and we would be
dancing and [ __ ] in the car dude and my
dad would I would and my dad looked a
little bit like [ __ ] George Harrison
and he would wear a [ __ ] chunky
blazer my dad would wear this chunky
blazer that was like [ __ ] white and
gray that's actually pretty so he had
long hair and I remember this my dad
would just [ __ ] it's really cool that
this podcast can go from guys group
[ __ ] face climbing and busting a nut
to me be reminiscing about my dad in a
lovely way from Berber - aw damn dude I
remember this [ __ ] wow this makes me
love my dad arse
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I did Wow this was in 1941 this
came out no in 1980 something and dude
my dad would be have his Mercedes and
and and I would be in the passenger seat
and given the first time he got a
[ __ ] Delta SAS car and I was like
well you're gonna get that car and he
got it and then we were playing with
this something and then he was played
with something and then he had his hand
on the shifter on the shipper gear and
he'd be having his other hand on the on
the steering wheel and I would look at
his veins were always like so big on his
[ __ ] hand and and I would always be
like well your page was so big and he
would be like that's not a whit that'll
be what happened to you when you get
older and I don't have big veins like
you and he'd be like yeah and then I
would poke his veins as he was driving
he be like stop doing that it's annoying
and I would be so mad that he wouldn't
[ __ ] let me poke his veins man
because I didn't have the veins yet and
I would say dad when I get older I
remember saying when I get older I can't
wait to [ __ ] poke my own veins dude
because you it sucks that you don't let
me [ __ ] poke your veins I remember
that [ __ ] oh we got another customer all
right well listen guys download the cash
app for free on the App Store or Google
Play market and two rewards code
congrats and get five dollars and give
five dollars two times that we can do
that download my app as well Chris
D'Elia app Saint Louis Missouri is
coming up st. Louis Missouri is coming
up Chicago I have so many Chicago shows
and then go get the links there is link
third they're still tickets left on the
third show in Chicago but that will sell
out so go if you're in Chicago go now
Cleveland Ohio Columbus coming up
Cincinnati Lexington Kentucky
Albuquerque Santa Fe Phoenix Phoenix
will be like
four thousand five thousand people or
something that's a big one and that's it
Hanover Huntington New York I think I
just added one which one that I just add
I just added a let me look right now and
I could tell you guys so you get a first
first dibs here if you're listening to
the someone in New York Huntington New
York I just added another third show in
Huntington we selling out my babies you
know how it goes that's how it goes dude
but thanks for listening subscribe to
the YouTube channel please and also
please subscribe to the what do you call
it they sing on iTunes and [ __ ] rate
and review that really helps us but
YouTube subscribe it to YouTube I mean
how many times does this go dude it's
not on kill is it well we're pissed
all right guys remember keep crossed
[Music]